hi there I'm here to discuss one of the
new fast-growing issues that many of us
are facing how to cancel plans when you
clearly have no plans long gone are the
days I'm sorry I would but I have a work
event or oh you know what I'm getting my
hair cut then getting my hair cut let's
be honest you haven't even washed your
hair since day one of the quarantine or
oh sorry I'm not on my phone I've been
on my phone for 36 hours and that's just
today why me I once got out of the
baptism by converting to Judaism then
the following week got out of a Bar
Mitzvah by converting down to
Catholicism you have any idea what kind
of dedication and paperwork that takes
you're looking at a pro a little word of
the wise if you're gonna pull that
maneuver a fruit basket to the rabbi and
the priest goes a very long way
that's my team KOCO reached out to me to
share some tips how best to get out of
any type of social situation first up an
old classic now to get out of facetiming
with a family member who's exclusively
getting their news from Facebook wish I
could pick up but I have to lie down on
the ground for 45 minutes and call it
exercise next up how to get out about
Google hangout with 12 cam friends you
don't even know anymore
seems easy right it's not they're
persistent Barney I have to call my
stockbroker and talk to him about how to
manage all the millions of stocks I
don't have and never will the Dow the
Dow what is the down just to get out of
that hey while we're all working from
home why don't we hop on a zoom wish I
could but this window isn't gonna stare
into itself and sing iris from Google
dulls and now let's go to a little bit
more complicated one I have to spend
this time alone making a large map sort
of like Claire Danes in homeland how
many people might be mad at me starting
from inch six and all just trying to get
out of a digital happy hour with your
best friend on Facebook why would you
really do that you love your best friend
introverts work never stops sorry I
gotta add my pitch dr. shark tank looks
like now is not exactly gonna be the
right time for me to sell my product I
kiss you on the mouth like seamless but
for kiss especially here's how to get
out of accepting a FaceTime answer the
damn call he might not have been right
for you or good but you know what it's
the end of the world he's a human being
and I'll tell you what those are hard
lock it down thank you so much for
listening see you next time someone get
me out of this thing how does it work